nearly 30 years ago
in a 1993 nike commercial professional
basketball legend charles barkley
fired the first shot at the role model
concept
popularized by columbia university
sociologist
robert k merton in the aftermath of the
1960s counter culture movement
barkley said i am not a role model
i'm not paid to be a role model i'm paid
to wreak havoc on a basketball court
parents should be role models just
because i can dunk a basketball
doesn't mean i should raise your kids
end quote
broccoli's words landed where they force
every bit to equal a former nfl
quarterback
colin kaepernick's national anthem knee
23 years later
vice president dan quayle defended
barkley while barclay's fellow nba
superstar carl malone
criticized him in sports illustrated
leading news magazines including time
and newsweek published articles
exploring the controversy newspaper
columnist from coast to coast
on and off the sports pages also weighed
in
the topic still sparks debate today
with the many phrases and concepts
merton coined
including self-fulfilling prophecy and
unintended consequences
role model has had the most impact on
the surface
the argument that young people tend to
model their behavior
after high profile successful adults is
harmless
however in retrospect the evolation
of athletes and other celebrities as
primary figures
in the formation of behavioral norms for
young people
help create the conditions that are
powering the destructive black lives
matter movement today
burton's role model concept undercuts
the importance of parents and nuclear
families
that was the point of barclay's
criticism feminists and other
progressive critics of america's
patriarchal society including the black
lives matter movement
whose marxist influence statement of
purpose opposes
the western prescribed nuclear family
structure
have used merton's concept to great
effect
muhammad ali peep rose farrah fawcett
barbara streisand mick jagger marvin
gaye
and burke reynolds infringed on
territory
primarily reserved for mom dad aunts
uncles grandparents and teachers
technology has helped advance the
process
diminishing the influence of traditional
authority figures
and strengthening the reach of
celebrities
kids shut their bedrooms doors turn on
their televisions
laptops and game consoles plug in
earbugs
open social media apps and disappear
into a world
far removed from mom and dad with a mere
push of a button
they tune out the world view of their
families and tune in the world view
of athletes like lebron james actress
lena dunham
rapper snoop dogg and social media race
baiter sean king
and of others like them on top of all
this
we now see america's enemies
particularly china
using these modern role models to
promote racial division
and destabilize our country with those
on the political left as their
accomplices
today they have co-laced around the
black lives matter movement
to push america toward a level of racial
dysfunction in animus
not experienced since the civil war it's
fitting that charles barkley fired the
first shot
against the trend because american
sports have become the gettysburg
of what some have called our cold civil
war
if china and the left complete their
radicalization of sports
our nation may never recover listen to
this quote from nelson mandela
sport has the power to change the world
it has the power to inspire
it has the power to unite people in a
way that little else does
it speaks to youth in a language they
understand
sport can create hope where once there
was only despair
it is more powerful than governments in
breaking down racial barriers
it laughs in the face of all types of
discrimination
that was nelson mandela the south
african freedom fighter turned statesman
spoke those words in an effort to heal
the country
he came to lead after spending a quarter
century incarcerated for opposing
apartheid
mandela embraced sports power to bridge
racial divides
looking on athletic competition is a
kind of antibiotic for racial animus and
discrimination
south africa's victory in the 1995 rugby
world cup
and mandela's presentation of the webb
ellis cup to team captain francois
pinar stand as an iconic symbol of unity
in post-apartheid south africa clint
eastwood directed a movie
invictus starring morgan freeman and
matt damon
that memorialize the important to the
moment it bears re-watching today
since sprinter jesse owens won four gold
medals
at the 1936 berlin olympics
and boxer joe lewis scored a first round
knockout
over german heavyweight maximeli in 1938
sports have served as a powerful racial
unifier
in america as well the victories earned
by owens and lewis
punctured hitler's aryan superiority
myth
unified black and white americans in
celebration
and established owens and lewis as the
country's
first black national heroes owen de
lewis
laid the foundation for brooklyn dodgers
general manager
branch rickey's partnership with jackie
robinson
to integrate our national pastime major
league baseball
a decade later robinson's successful
integration of baseball in turn inspired
dr martin luther king jr
rosa parks and the civil rights movement
of the 1950s indeed
barack obama america's first black
president the world's first black leader
of a predominantly white country
credited robinson's career
for his own political rise obama said
there's a direct line between jackie
robinson
and me standing here he said that in
january
2017 while hosting the world champion
chicago cubs at the white house obama
went on to say
there's a direct line between people
loving ernie banks
and then the city being able to come
together and work together in one spirit
sometimes it's just a matter of us being
able to escape and relax from the
difficulties of our days
but sometimes it also speaks to
something better in us
and when you see this group of folks of
different shades
and different backgrounds and coming
from different communities
and neighborhoods and all across the
country
and then playing as one team and playing
the right way
and celebrating each other and being
joyous in that
that tells us a little something about
what america is
and what america can be yeah
america is a shining example of sports
transformative power
the games we play the games at the
center of our social behavior
combined with our founding principles to
enhance
the american experience america's
enemies know this
which is why the culture war has moved
to our
arenas and stadiums sports are now in
the same crosshairs
as our founding fathers under attack
for past racial sins and unappreciated
for their vital role in cultivating
racial unity
thomas jefferson owned slaves but by
writing
the declaration of independence he made
the emancipation of black slaves
inevitable american sports were once
segregated
but no american industry can match
sports empowerment of black men
the black player-dominated national
football league
is the most powerful force in american
popular culture
it provides the number one television
show on
five different television networks cbs
fox nbc espn
and the nfl network in this era of have
it your way tv
where consumers record and watch shows
when they want
while fast forwarding through
advertisements
only the live sporting events can be
consistently counted on
to deliver audiences that sit through
commercials
but while american sports have never
been more influential
they've also never been more vulnerable
to foreign influence
their partnership with global brands and
their desire to build global audiences
have given foreign countries a pathway
to manipulate
american sports and culture look at how
china
with its 1.4 billion consumers
rules the national basketball
association and its de facto parent
company
nike the same way it rules hollywood
access to china's consumers and asia's
cheap labor
even sometimes slave labor is the key to
nike's economic growth
the portland-based shoe and apparel
manufacturer generates
40 billion a year in revenue its global
reach
agenda and revenue streams dictate the
strategy
of the 8 billion a year nba
many are unaware that nike and not the
nba
controls basketball one could make a
fair argument
that the nba is nothing more than the
in-house marketing department
of nike both nike and the nba
kowtow to china which explains their
silence
on the horrific human rights abuses
inside china
and the suppression of hong kong freedom
fighters
by china's communist government more
important
nike in the nba's china agenda helps
explain why
nike pitch man lebron james and colin
kaepernick
enthusiastically smear the united states
as inherently racist and evil from
joseph stalin
to fidel castro to our own time the
communist
favorite propaganda tactic has been to
paint the west
and the u.s in particular as races
the militant social justice messaging of
james and kaepernick
serves the interest not only of the
chinese communist party
and globalist corporations like nike but
also
of our political left kaepernick's
national anthem defiance in 2016
gave the left an opportunity to
politicize football
america's new national pastime and force
it into the kind of progressive
posturing already commonplace in the nba
and hollywood arrogance lack of
foresight
and the advice of an inner circle that
included
former clinton administration press
secretary joe lockhart
as the nfl's vice president of
communications
explained commissioner roger goodell's
la say fair approach to kaepernick's
protest
underestimating the determination of the
left and the power of social media
to intimidate corporate america goodell
and the nfl's tv partners
wrongly thought the kaepernick
controversy would
fade over time instead
four years after kaepernick first knelt
the leftist mob has forced the national
football league
major league baseball the national
hockey league
and the national basketball association
to take their own needs
and pay homage to the dishonest black
lives matter narrative
on police brutality the nfl plans to
paint
social justice messaging across its end
zones this season
and to allow players to wear helmet
decals with the names of alleged police
victims
the san francisco 49ers fly a black
lives matter flag
next to the american flag at levi's
stadium
major league baseball opened its covet
shortened season
with blm carved into the pitcher's mound
and the boston red sox put up a 254-foot
blm billboard outside fenway park
nhl players are now regularly kneeling
during the national anthem
the nba's basketball bubble at disney
world is a virtual
shrine to blm black lives matters is
painted on the court
players wear social justice messages on
the back of their jerseys
and it's major news now when a player
stands during the national anthem
the entire american sports world a
culture that traditionally
celebrates victor's meritocracy color
blindness and patriotism
has suddenly immersed itself in black
victimization
and left-wing radicalism this immersion
threatens to do permanent damage to
american culture as a whole
it is certainly undermined national
pride
a country that no longer believes in its
founding ideals
cannot prosper and survive
if our sports stadiums and arenas have
become the gettysburg of the culture war
lebron james and colin kaepernick are
playing the roles
of general robert e lee and stonewall
jackson fighting to divide the nation
even further than it is the mainstream
media is only half right in casting them
as modern day equivalents
of muhammad ali ali's religious sect
the nation of islam was certainly
divisive
it championed black succession but
unlike the blm movement
it also rejected victimhood its founder
elijah muhammad
and its spokesman malcolm x promoted
bootstrap
self-reliance and were disdainful of
liberal politics
malcolm x said the worst enemy that the
negro
has is this white man that runs around
here
drooling at the mouth professing to love
negroes
and calling himself a liberal it is
following these white liberals
that has perpetuated problems that the
negroes have
if the negro wasn't taken tricked or
deceived by the white liberal
the negroes would get together and solve
our own problems
i only cite these things to show you
that in america
the history of the white liberal has
been nothing but a series of trickery
designed to make negroes think the white
liberal was going to solve our problems
that was malcolm x pro blm athletes
today
have moved beyond the idea of role model
that was debated in 1993
the idea of modeling behavior to be
imitated
such as self-reliance hard work
responsibility
and good parenthood through the power of
social media
to which they are addicted these modern
role models
exert influence by promoting commercial
products and political causes in the
case of nba athletes like lebron james
this means turning their backs not only
on the oppressed people of china and
hong kong
but also the poor and underprivileged in
america
among whom so many of these wealthy
athletes grew up
and who they now condemn to victimhood
and dependency with their political
activism
charles barkley was right 30 years ago
parents
not athletes should be role models today
the situation is even worse
with sports further dividing and already
dangerously divided nation rather than
providing the unifying
and ever healing force nelson mandela
described predictably there are now
calls to boycott sports and it seems
inevitable
that the tv ratings of the pro sports
leagues will decline
this is unlikely to matter however to
the suddenly woke billionaire team
owners
and their hand-picked commissioners as
fans
we can only hope and pray that these
feckless leaders
will reconsider their embrace of the blm
cult
a necessary first step to returning
american sports
to what it has been in the past a force
for unity
and a model of a diverse and colorblind
meritocracy